I was a specialist in the United States Army
and served in Fort Bragg, North Carolina.
I'm a native Michigan resident, and so I already
knew about Hillsdale. It's a true quality
education. Coming out, that's what I want.
I want to learn stuff, not just get a piece
of paper, you know? The fact that they don't
accept government money is so they can teach
what they truly believe without inference
from the government. I think it's a really
important part of Hillsdale. When they don't
accept government money, of course, that includes
the GI bill. That would be a big concern except
for they offer military scholarships, and
those in my case, are a full ride. It includes
where I live, which isn't just a normal dorm.
It's off campus, a house. It includes tuition,
it includes a book stipend of $500, it includes meals
The professors really seem to care. If you
come up and ask them questions, they're going
to take a personal interest in making sure
you understand the subject they're teaching.
They also care as far as to whether you're
actually there or not. It's so small that
they actually can care. The transition from
the military to here was good. I'm on the
football team too so there's a little bit
of that physicalness still in there. If you're
a little bit behind because like me, you've
been out for a long time, they really take
a patience and work with you, and they understand
that you haven't been doing that like everybody
else has for four years straight.
Everything's just very well put together with
the athletics, and it's not so much that it's
focused on athletics, and that's what you
expected to only do, because the focus is
still on education.